це не тест випробуваного міністра у почту
та наукою України Сергій аш карлото
панаменістр я вас вітаю у нашому ефірі
Слава Україні
героїв Слава Доброго дня
владний парламент хвали до законопроекту
про субливість у степовій компанії
2023 і було багато навіть
я буду проходи ти там острів Ні два
предмета ц
українська та математика історія на вибір
і ось класна харчування його на блок
ключовим скажи шпилька вирішено все ж
харчування та які зміни все-таки були
внесенні Які ось фінальні рішення
мультиметром
хочу сказати що дійство парламент
вирішили про змії на 23
[музика]
аналога предметний тест речі будуть
народними депутатами
на сьогодні ледве блоки я був українським
мовною математикою та
блок дисципліна одним з них які є
історії України явно пішов історію
прояви я б не предметом дітей у
моїх знають усі непотрібні
України називаються
абіту
вступати на шкірну зібраних
спеціальностей
[музика]
для всіх спеціальностей
тестові Балі
це одна і важливі речі CS рівня про
джерелумов знайти шкіру українські
випускник і Майя розракова ти на що б
сам це українських Захід євросвіти
Незалежності
на території України
атласність
за кордоном будуть для них ці зради
тому що я знаю що ви плануєте
все-таки онлайн все ж таки таке
нібито
наших
перебування зараз
[музика]
натиснули
і шкірних та
[музика]
опубліковано
і до укупування території
напруження Миколаївської Херсонської
області їх ланки на початку листопада
будуть для цих клієнтів в пензель витягом
друк здачі відставання
теж
актуальності
зустрічатися
вчителями
[музика]
у тому числі з Миколаївської області
І в чому, наприклад, у херсонниця потрібні у
вас тут на цій вийшов допустим годинник на
Виборзькій області такий самий
і
у тому тексті на сьогодні 4 будуть
прицінюватися без держав написано
[музика]
онлайн приходять до школи тому що ми
кидаємо ось я
початковий Рік у харкові е-е у Харкові
зараз обстрілювали росіяни там із муші
не було іншому чат якщо онлайн ось все
такі Як зараза Сердитий
[музика]
424 школи вимкнено в онлайн режимі
школа 9 років і швидко на 40 було 45 км
зоні там газону постільного
травня укриття на сьогодні та
4.340 тисяч євро
Пана Сергіївна Ми з вами вже говорили
про тих дітей кізара знаходитесь за
кордоном дуже багату Я знаю хоче
повертатись назад в Україну на туман
спілкується Ось і міс цілих школах І в
чаті онлайн
волі доладно Ще б могли порадувати
таким батькам таким учителем
такі харчування
е-е Які курсові преіфільства як
працюють годинника були бувають на території
України буде України він і маят
повністю
законодавства ті ігри досить бувають
середні Євген
закону та нормативу навчати сидіть щоб
не перебивали на території
онлайн паралельно в українській школі
виключили за бажанням бійців
в Україні
ефестилі інструменти
будете і сказали
теми простіше
таких щоб все-таки ваш
Ось це паралельно спілкуватися все щодня
ми можемо
абсолютно